so lolli Warren sealed her from Finland
decided to bring in some help
his hydraulic press that is a seriously
impressive piece of kit I have always
wanted to know if this was possible must
be able to do it more than seven times
if you have enough power time to find
out tom
whoa I've never seen paper like that it
completely transformed
it's just crumbling to bits Lowry's
crushing prowess won him over 100
million hits online in less than a year
we went to Finland to find out why the
Internet is obsessed with the press
there is always that excitement
what will be inside of that thing or a
bullet explode when I fold at the 7th
time I was thinking that this is my last
fold and something bad is going to
happen with that pressed but the
explosion was surprised for for me it's
very hard and brittle I think we cannot
fold it more than 7 times we taped our
press so why did the paper explode the
tremendous force required to create the
seventh fold actually causes the paper
to crack and break this means that the
hydraulic press slams down a very short
distance very very quickly this press
can create a thousand killer Newton's of
force that's the equivalent of 20
African elephants standing on this bit
of paper when Lowry takes a look at the
folded paper it no longer access paper
this happens because the paper is
printer paper which has been coated with
calcium carbonate which is basically
rock the immense force of the hydraulic
press causes the crystal structure in
the calcium carbonate to collapse
resulting in a very brittle very flaky
material Larry you can crush paper but
what about scissors and stone I accept
your challenge
we made some kind of rock pancake
that was exciting so now we are done
paper rock scissors and press beans
every time thanks Larry we're glad you
pressed on